hey everybody Jim here I'm cheating a
little bit of behind the scenes for this
episode because this is probably going
to be the most elaborate makeup that
I've ever had to do for an NC when Doug
came up with the idea to do the review
where he wanted became to me a little
over a month ago probably and he was
like I really want to do Planet of the
Apes the Tim Burton plan of the Apes and
would it be possible for you to make me
look like Tim Roth's character and that
movie and I was like yeah that would be
awesome to do I would love to do that
however it's always a little trickier to
prepare for these sort of things because
our shooting schedule is usually really
tight so we don't have a lot of time on
the day on set it's a super elaborate
makeup you know it's like a full head
really um makeup job and so it poses
some challenges normally what I would do
if I was doing this intensive makeup is
I would make a mold of the actors face
in this case Doug and have a plaster
positive and then I would sculpt all the
features and stuff like that on that and
make another mold and then pour foam
latex into it and have a foam latex
appliance that I could put on his face
that was designed specifically for his
face and it would fit perfectly and he
can remote motion and and everything
through the makeup and stuff however
because I don't have really the time to
do that in order to do that Doug yet to
come in and it's a few hours the process
of making a mold and everything so we're
not gonna do that
also Doug in order to stay in character
week after week has to keep his goatee
so being that most of the appliance is
going to be glued around that area it
makes it very tricky how the appliance
is actually gonna adhere to his face how
it's gonna work so those are a couple of
little challenges that we have going
into this already like every project I
never know exactly how I'm gonna do it
how it's gonna come out in this case I'm
just gonna have to sculpt a very generic
face type and hope that it fits Doug
generally well I gotta open hopefully it
fits them and I can apply it quickly and
without too much fuss you know we're on
the day filming Doug is very involved in
all aspects you know he's directing he's
you know acting up obviously and you
know he's supervising the script or he's
supervising the script and stuff so he
doesn't have a lot of time to sit in the
makeup chair and this is going to be one
of the most elaborate makeups we've ever
had to do so it's it's hard to say how
long it'll take
hopefully I can get it and I can build
an appliance that we can do in just like
a like an hour and a half application um
but we'll see yeah hey you still have no
idea how I'm gonna do this but that's
totally cool I love the challenge and so
I think what I my plan is is to create a
very simple face structure I probably
use a vacuum for mold that I have is a
very basic face and then I'll sculpt on
that and make a mold out of plaster and
then just have a liquid latex I'm going
to use a heavy grade liquid latex for
the actual appliances and I'm going to
try and keep it in as much of one
appliance as possible so it'll be easier
to put on I'm not exactly sure how it's
gonna turn out but I'm going to keep
shooting some video and stuff of the
process and so you guys would kind of
see how it all comes together and yeah
hopefully it comes together okay so
we're in the workshop and like I said so
I'm gonna use a basic this is a vacuum
form of a basic face shape
that I'm gonna sculpt on and I have to
hopefully it'll come out like this it
look like Tim Roth and Planet of the
Apes this is my reference I'm gonna use
sculpey original to do all the sculpt
all the features it's not the most ideal
as far as price wise but I have a ton of
this stuff so that's why I'm actually
gonna use it at night I am very
comfortable using sculpey it's a really
it's really easy to use polymer clay and
yeah I've only got like a few hours
really to get this done so I'm just
gonna just jump right into it and see
what happens and hopefully when it's
done it resembles this and in some
manner so let's see what happens
[Music]
all right so I'm not the the basic kind
of shape of the face done the trick I
think in order to make it look like not
just a generic monkey face and to look
somewhat more like the Tim Roth
character is he has a very specific no
like shape of the nose so that's kind of
what I'm working on now I feel like if I
can kind of make that work and it's
looking like how I want it to look then
the rest of it'll kind of just come
together but yeah so far that's about
that's what I got and the nose kind of
working out now the overall structure of
the face too is very almost very
menacing it's supposed to be very
menacing he's the villain so he's got
kind of like a heavier brow very deep
set almost like cheekbones kind of kind
of skeletal looking so you can kind of
make out his features much more
this is what we're left with I think
it'll get the job done try and get in
close there you can kind of see some of
the detailing I don't know it's kind of
hard to tell it's all white but I did
put a lot of deep lines and stuff like
that and to kind of give it a texture
hopefully then when I paint it all that
will come out and really give it some
more depth and see yeah well it's kind
of hard to tell but that's the the basic
gist there
it looks pretty yeah that's not too bad
actually side by side yeah as I said
it's about what I have time for today
and I'll make the mold for the latex and
yeah hopefully they'll all come together
I'm pretty excited to see it
all right so I came in just this morning
and I kind of was looking at the mask or
I I make the mold I wanted to add a
little bit more the forehead yesterday I
kind of just had the brow but I think
I'm gonna end the forehead enough I
don't like it I can always remove it
there's still a lot of detail in the
forehead on the character or whatever so
I just went ahead and added that little
piece
I'll keep it really thin with the latex
and then way that way you can still kind
of a moat and move his brows and you
know and stuff like that and it'll give
me a little bit more of a surface area
to adhere the whole prosthetic to again
I have no idea that's a good idea or a
bad idea but you know we'll see what
happens so anyway today we're gonna make
the mold I'm gonna pour plaster mold
we'll build a box around it pour the
mold pull the clay out and then we will
yeah pour the latex in and let it sit
overnight and tomorrow it should be good
we can do a test so
all right so I created a box a simple
box around the sculpt and I will just
mix up some of this plaster of Paris
it's two parts plus your pairs per one
part cold water yeah I'm gonna mix it up
brush out of the first coat and then
pour it in a little bit at a time and
kind of kind of banging on it tap on it
to kind of force the bubbles out and
yeah about an hour or so it should
probably cure up and then we can pull
out the clay and see what we have so
we're gonna do that right
all right well I pulled the pulled the
clay out and were left with this
negative here and you can kind of see it
actually came out really well I was
actually able to pull the clay out all
in one go it retained almost all of the
detail and stuff with the the mask is
actually still there it's still pretty
much intact I mean there's a little bit
of smudging and damage and stuff that
could be easily cleaned up but usually I
have to scrape out some of the residual
clay and stuff like that that's in there
especially when it's there's that much
tooling and stuff like that involved but
yeah I'm actually really happy with the
way it came out it pulled beautifully I
think would get a really nice clean mask
out of this and yeah that's gonna be the
next step so I'm gonna pour liquid latex
in brush it in real good I'm gonna use a
professional grade latex that's used for
we're making Halloween masks and stuff
like that and I would get a really good
test from that I would think tomorrow we
should have a really cool prosthetic
that we can test out
all right so here's the here's the mask
the latex appliance
came up pretty good actually it might
about a little bit of shrinkage I'm not
sure but I think it'll be a pretty good
fit and then it's got the chin piece
here and of course I have to add all the
hair and stuff like that but I think I'm
gonna try I'm gonna do a quick test on
myself and see how good I can kind of
apply it and make it look I don't think
I have hair and stuff like that to add
to it today but can maybe do a quick
makeout jab and see how all comes
together I know
but oh well I'm pretty happy with the
the appliance itself I think it came out
pretty well this is actually a really
nice a really good latex that's I think
I might have mentioned it's designed for
making latex masks like Halloween masks
and stuff like that so so yeah it's
pretty good it's really solid
flexible it's still gonna be I think
pliable and lightweight enough to wear
yeah
pretty cool dog will be able to wear
you
[Music]